[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
Este es un episodio dedicado a mianmar
el primero de febrero de 2021 el
ejército birmano tomó el poder poniendo
fin de forma abrupta a un paréntesis
democrático de una década en el espacio
de unos pocos meses miles de civiles
fueron asesinados y otros miles fueron
encarcelados mientras se formaba
rápidamente Un gobierno en la sombra
también se organizaba la resistencia
Armada en un país aislado del resto del
mundo y en autarquía con este reportaje
exclusivo rodado en el maquis Rebelde y
en los círculos clandestinos de la
resistencia prodemocrática los
reporteros civil payén orán chavea y
fabrice Peral hacen un balance de la
guerra civil los disidentes en el exilio
militares Rebeldes y desertores del
ejército birmano testifican y denuncian
el creciente y decisivo apoyo de Rusia
aquí la historia
[Música]
es el comienzo de la temporada de
lluvias de 2022 esta es la sexta brigada
de la rebelión del pueblo cayín en algún
lugar del sureste de myanmar hoy es un
día de Alianza entre bandos rivales
Buenos días
salud me gustaría agradecerle a sousalon
por haber decidido acompañarnos esta
mañana
no Esta es una alianza histórica
ahora Estamos unidos como hermanos
hermanos de armas
nosotros los cayen estamos ahora unidos
podemos luchar juntos por la libertad
por la libertad de nuestra nación Juntos
por la victoria gracias
[Música]
los principales apoyos de la tag madau
el ejército birmano vienen de Rusia y
china con la Guerra de Ucrania sabemos
que los rusos están en grandes problemas
así que Esperamos que armen menos a
nuestros enemigos Por lo menos menos que
antes
nos bombardean con sus aviones de
combate nos enfrentamos a muchos
disparos de misiles y cohetes atacan
especialmente a la población civil
pero ya tenemos algunas medidas
entendemos sus tácticas no estamos
preocupados
estoy feliz de volver a la organización
madre nuestro deber es estar juntos para
aplastar a los militares birmanos esos
dictadores birmanos que oprimen a
nuestro pueblo
jóvenes viejos hombres o mujeres del
campo y de las ciudades estos
resistentes prodemocracia han venido de
todo myanmar para unirse a las
rebeliones étnicas estoy orgullosa de
estar aquí lo que está haciendo la junta
es horrible no podía quedarme sin hacer
nada Lucharé hasta el final
y también están las conquistas de guerra
como este soldado birmano que de ser
todo de su Batallón para unirse a los
insurgentes
pide demasiadas injusticias no podía
quedarme un día más en ese ejército
no me preocupa mi familia en casa al
principio estaban asustados pero ahora
están bien yo les aporto sobre todo mi
experiencia militar a mis camaradas
venceremos
ha pasado un año y medio desde que
mianmar se sumió de nuevo en el terror
el primero de febrero de 2021 El golpe
de estado del General mina ungine
devolvió el país a sus viejos tiempos
dictatoriales
puso un sangriento fin a un paréntesis
democrático de 10 años dejando miles de
Muertos cientos de miles de desplazados
15.000 presos políticos
pero también hay resistencia
en todos los frentes estas se organiza y
se enfrenta al gobierno birmano todos
estos jóvenes son estudiantes que
eligieron luchar huyeron hacia la selva
para sumarse al ejército clandestino de
las fuerzas de defensa popular
estoy dispuesto a morir por mi país
quiero luchar contra los militares
quiero matarlos ahora
[Música]
en algún lugar más al sur en el estado
de cayem de myanmar
aquí nunca se sabe los birmanos pueden
venir pero intentamos asegurarnos de que
el lugar sea seguro
pero ahora es muy arriesgado venir aquí
y además durante la temporada de lluvias
esta pista es imposible de usarlo
Hace tres semanas hubo gente del pueblo
de allá que vino a refugiarse aquí en
las cuevas especialmente mujeres que
tenían miedo
los recientes bombardeos de la Aviación
birmana causaron muchos daños en esta
región
este misionero católico se arriesga para
ayudar a la población civil
las primeras Víctimas de los combates
[Música]
antes
en estas aldeas de primera línea los
habitantes están atrapados en los
combates todos son desplazados internos
El golpe de estado afectó a muchas
personas
especialmente a los jóvenes
por ejemplo ella huyó de rangun y Su
futuro es incierto en cuanto hay
tensiones se van a las Cuevas
[Música]
de hecho el problema para nosotros es
que hay Rebeldes a la derecha otros
Rebeldes cayena a la izquierda y el
ejército birmano por todas partes
siempre tenemos miedo porque nos acusan
de estar confabulados con ellos
siempre represalias contra los pueblos
por eso la gente huye llevamos meses
viviendo así
una vez más la guerra civil de myanmar
se ha replegado sobre sí misma todos los
accesos al país están cerrados al otro
lado de la frontera Tailandia se ha
convertido en un santuario para miles de
refugiados políticos perseguidos por los
militares
[Música]
los residentes del estado de Chan La de
chapping longing Están preocupados por
los refuerzos del ejército birmano
desplegados en la región temen un
recrudecimiento de los combates en la
zona
en realidad primero quería graduarme y
luego mi idea era llevar una vida normal
pero por ahora todo ha cambiado
no tiene 23 años desde hace varios meses
vive clandestinamente en una aldea de la
frontera tailandesa es la voz y el
rostro de uno de los canales de
televisión de la oposición más vistos en
myanmar un canal de televisión que
funciona con un presupuesto reducido
hace mucho calor y creo que hoy estoy un
poco nerviosa
el gobierno de la resistencia anunció
que todas las propiedades y posesiones
del jefe de la junta militar el general
mina online serán confiscadas
así como la de todos los dirigentes
militares
en esta casa viven unos 15 periodistas y
activistas es un lugar Secreto del que
nunca salen
he trabajado
esto es el símbolo de nuestra revolución
el 3 de febrero tres días después del
golpe dice nunca olvidar nunca perdonar
es simple
Sí claro estoy un poco aburrida aquí
porque estamos lejos de casa en un país
extranjero Y además estamos encerrados
aquí cuando estaba en mi al mar solía
salir veía gente ahora ya no así que me
concentro en mi trabajo pero es difícil
estar aquí la clandestinidad las
dificultades la imposibilidad de saber
lo que va a pasar
tengo que Mostrar mi cara en público me
preocupa constantemente mi familia que
se quedó en mí al mar su seguridad
vivo con el miedo a las represalias
contra ellos Temo que el ejército haga
la conexión y los encuentre todos
corremos muchos riesgos aquí pero el
principal temor es por nuestros
parientes nuestras familias en casa
unos meses después del golpe de estado
los parlamentarios disidentes formaron
Un gobierno en la sombra un poder
paralelo con diplomáticos y ministros
todos fueron condenados a muerte en
myanmar
[Música]
cuando uno ve el sacrificio de nuestro
pueblo no tenemos el apoyo que merecemos
en el pueblo birmano está dispuesto a
llegar hasta el final están luchando
muriendo por la democracia por un futuro
democrático en Así que llamamos a la
comunidad internacional a las naciones
democráticas para que vengan a ayudarnos
deberían venir a nuestra ayuda deberían
venir a nuestra ayuda
pese a no contar con ayuda externa la
insurrección se organiza cueste lo que
cueste y marca puntos multiplicando los
golpes contra el régimen cada vez hay
más soldados que desertan nos
encontramos con uno de ellos en un lugar
secreto de la frontera
todo lo que tenemos en términos de alta
tecnología militar en Llamar es enviado
por Rusia y todo el resto del armamento
y equipo lo proporciona china en lo que
respecta a la seguridad de nuestros
dirigentes el apoyo proviene de Corea
del Norte y a veces también de Pakistán
para la tecnología básica pero los
aviones de combate los misiles y los
radares y sobre todo los nuevos sistemas
de vigilancia telefónica y de internet
todo procede exclusivamente del ejército
ruso personalmente estoy profundamente
convencido de que sin el apoyo técnico
aéreo ruso nuestro ejército ya estaría
Derrotado
los generales birmanos pensaron que
podían derrocar al gobierno elegido y
establecer su poder por ahora no lo han
logrado el pueblo resiste mientras
mianmar desciende trágicamente hacia una
guerra civil hasta aquí reporteros de la
semana recuerda que para sintonizar esta
y las emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]